افتتاح ان هادئ مع بعض الجدل رغم غياب
مثلي الجدل مهرجان القاهره السينمائي في
دورته الرابعه والاربعين
[موسيقى]
معظم الحضور بازياء انيقه ومنهم بازياء
غير مناسبه وجريئه احيانا لكن المحتشم
يغلب هل هو التزام بالدرسكود الذي طلب به
رئيس المهرجان ام لبروده الطقس كلمه
الجدل منذ تولي حسين فهمي رئاسه المهرجان
بعد غياب طويل عنها مصرا على ان الحضور
يجب ان يرتدوا ملابس تليق بقيمه المهرجان
على الرغم من ذلك هناك بعض الفنانين لم
يلتزموا به على راسهم مدير المهرجان
المخرج امير رمسيس حيث ارتدى ستره بيضاء
في مخالفه صريحه بان يرتدي الرجال بدله
سوداء وربطه سوداء
[موسيقى]
ادوارد الفنان المصري ارتدى بدله كحليه
اما الفنان اللبنانيه دومينيك حوراني يبدو
انها كضيفه لم تسمع بالدرس كود او لم
تلتزم به باطلاله جريئه بفستان احمر عاري
الضهر ومفتوح من الجانب بينما يجبروا
الدرس هود السيدات على ارتداء فستان طويل
وبدوني فتحات
[موسيقى]
الفنان احمد الفيشاوي المعروف باثارته
الجدل ضرب بالدرس كود عرض الحائط وارتدى
بدله بلون وردي وبالتاكيد بدون ربطه عنق
ويبدو ان حسين فهمي كانت جادا في موضوع
الالتزام بالزيت حتى انه حسب فيديو متداول
احرج صديقته الاعلاميه بوسي شلبي بعد
طلبها التصوير معه على التابلت وفاجاها
قائلا مش هتصور معك بالفستان
[موسيقى]